THE MORE SOPHISTICATED HOSPITALS
HERE.
TEARS FOR A MUCH LOVED
COLLEAGUE, KILLED BY COVID-19 IN
THE SAME HOSPITAL WHERE HE'D
SPENT A YEAR TREATING OTHER
VICTIMS OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
GRIEF AND THE INEVITABLE SILENT
QUESTION, WHO'S NEXT.
HE DIED HERE IN THIS INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT BECAUSE THE HOSPITAL
WHERE HE WORKED RAN OUT OF THE
MOST BASIC NECESSITY, OXYGEN.
HE WAS NOT ALONE.
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF THE
HOSPITAL, DR. GUPTA, GAVE THE
MID-AFTERNOON CASUALTY FIGURES
IN THIS WAR AGAINST THE VIRUS.
>> EIGHT PATIENTS DIED TODAY,
DIED JUST NOW.
AND FIVE PATIENTS, THEY'RE UNDER
RESUSCITATION.
THEY MAY OR MAY NOT SURVIVE.
JUST BECAUSE IN THE CAPITAL CITY
OF DELHI AND BECAUSE OF -- THIS
IS THE LIFE.
>> Reporter: HE KNEW THE CHANCES
OF REVIVING THE FIVE WERE SLIM.
WHEN YOU HEARD THIS MORNING THAT
YOU HAD JUST A FEW HOURS OF
OXYGEN AND THEN EIGHT PATIENTS
DIED, WHAT DOES THAT DO TO YOU,
TO THE SOUL OF A DOCTOR?
>> I CANNOT EXPLAIN MY FEELING.
WE'RE DYING INSIDE.
WE'RE THE SAVIORS, NOT THE
MURDERERS.
WE CANNOT EXPRESS OUR FEELINGS.
I CANNOT EXPRESS MY FEELING, HOW
I'M FEELING INSIDE.
>> IS IT DESTROYING YOU?
>> YES.
>> HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN A
DOCTOR?
>> WHAT, SIR?
>> HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN A
DOCTOR?
>> FOR 35 YEARS.
>> IT MUST BE SO DESTROYING.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT IT MUST BE
LIKE FOR YOU.
I'M SORRY.
>> I'M SORRY, SIR.
>> Reporter: OVER THE NEXT HOUR,
FOUR OF THE FIVE RESUSCITATION
PATIENTS DIED.
WHEN THE OXYGEN RAN OUT, 12
PEOPLE DIED IN THIS HOSPITAL,
WHICH IN EVERY OTHER RESPECT IS
A FIRST WORLD FACILITY.
THEY SIMPLY ASPHYXIATED.
THE HOSPITAL COPES BY ADVISING
PATIENTS TO SOURCE THEIR OWN
SUPPLIES OF OXYGEN TO COVER ITS
ERRATIC SUPPLIES.
LOCAL AND INTERNATIONAL EFFORTS
TO GET ENOUGH OF THE GAS TO
INDIA'S CAPITAL ARE STILL
FAILING.
INDIA'S CENTRAL AND NATIONAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
EXPLAIN THE OXYGEN SHORTAGES,
AND AS THE NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
INFECTED WITH COVID-19 SOAR IN
INDIA ALONG WITH THE DAILY DEATH
TOLL, THIS HOSPITAL LIKE MANY
OTHERS WILL ADMIT NO MORE
PATIENTS.
THERE'S NO POINT.
>> WE WILL NOT TAKE MORE
PATIENTS BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO DIE IN FRONT OF US.
THEY CAN GO TO THE HOSPITALS
WHERE THE OXYGEN IS AVAILABLE.
>> Reporter: HE RUNS A HINDU
CHARITY.
HE PULLED THROUGH COVID BEFORE
THE OXYGEN RAN OUT.
>> TEEN NURSING STAFF, THE
SUPERVISORS ARE NOW WORKING VERY
HARD.
>> Reporter: FAIR ENOUGH.
BUT THE INDIA'S GOVERNMENT'S
FAILURE TO SUPPLY HOSPITALS
DURING A PANDEMIC IS SIMPLY NOT
GOING TO WASH.
NOW, BRIANNA, THE CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO SAY IT'S
GOT THIS UNDER CONTROL.
THIS MAN IS BARELY ABLE TO
RELEASE HIS NAME AND HE'S
TOTALLY RELIABLE ON THIS
DONATION OF OXYGEN, BUT THIS IS
THE VIEW BEING EXPRESSED BY THE
NATIONAL GOVERNMENT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> Reporter: JOHN, THE SUPREME
COURT HAS NOW INTERVENED TO
FORCE THE CENTRAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS TO UP THEIR GAME
WHEN IT COMES TO DELIVERING
VACCINES, AND AT THE SAME TIME
THE CENTRAL GOVERNMENT'S JUST
ANNOUNCED IT'S GOING TO BE
MOBILIZING MEDICAL STUDENTS TO
TRY TO COPE WITH THIS COVID
PANDEMIC, BUT IT'S MOST
CERTAINLY ON THE BACK FOOT AND
TRYING TO SPIN ITS WAY OUT ON
WHAT IS A HUMANITARIAN
CATASTROPHE.
JOHN?
>> YOU CAN'T SPIN YOUR WAY OUT
OF PEOPLE DYING BEFORE YOUR
EYES, SUFFOCATING BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OXYGEN.
HE CAN SAY QUOTAS ARE BEING MET,
BUT THE QUOTAS NEED TO BE HIGHER
CLEARLY IF IT'S NOT ENOUGH AT
THIS POINT.
SAM, I KNOW A LOT OF COUNTRIES
ARE SENDING RELIEF TO INDIA.
HAS IT ARRIVED?
IS IT MAKING A DIFFERENCE?
>> WELL, WE'VE SEEN NO EVIDENCE
OF IT ON THE GROUND.
THESE CYLINDERS HAVE COME MANY
HUNDREDS OF MILES.
THERE'S NO OXYGEN TO BE FOUND AT
ALL IN DELHI.
WE HAVE SEEN THE TELEVISION
PICTURES AS YOU HAVE OF THIS AID
POURING IN FROM THE UNITED
STATES, UNITED KINGDOM, GERMANY,
FRANCE, SINGAPORE.
YOU NAME IT, THEY'RE GIVING.
AND YET WE'RE NOT SEEING IT
HITTING THE STREETS AT ALL.
IN TERMS OF THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT'S ARGUMENT THAT DELHI
IS GETTING MORE OXYGEN THAN IT'S
ASKED FOR, IT'S SIMPLY A
FALLACY.
IT'S ASKED FOR AT LEAST 600 TONS
A DAY.
AND THE OTHER DAY ALL THAT WAS
DELIVERED WAS 490.
HE'S FACTUALLY INCORRECT AS WELL
AS POLITICALLY BIZARRE, FRANKLY.
>> THE KEY ELEMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IS PUBLIC TRUST AND ONCE
YOU LOSE IT, IT'S HARD TO GET IT
BACK.
REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT TO
WATCH YOUR REPORT, SAM, AND TO
HEAR FROM THAT DOCTOR, OVER 45
YEARS ON THE JOB, NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
YOU CAN TELL HIS HEART IS BROKEN
AND HE NEEDS TO KEEP ON WORKING.
OUR BEST TO YOU AND YOUR TEAM,
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORTING.
>> SAM HAS REALLY BEEN SOME OF
OUR EYES AND EARS ON THE GROUND
THERE, JOHN.
I THINK ONE OF THINGS THAT'S SO
DISTURBING ABOUT WATCHING THIS
IS IT FEELS LIKE SOMETHING YOU
MIGHT HAVE SEEN OVER A YEAR AGO,
BUT TO IMAGINE THAT THEY WEREN'T
PREPARED WITH OXYGEN, IT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM -- THERE'S NO
EXCUSE FOR IT.
>> AND ALSO TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
MIGHT STILL BE TO COME.
THINK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IN
TERMS OF VACCINATION, ALMOST